à l'heure du dépouillement hervé morin
n'a encore que des sourires à opposer
aux amis qui le pressent déjà de donner
des nouvelles
depuis 17h sortez les urssaf aimons
tellement j'ai fait la sieste jusqu'à la
mairie dépeignent offre un cadre
rassurant sa liste il fait carton plein
mais très vite parviennent les premiers
résultats partiels des bureaux tests ce
qui indique les tendances fiable le
sondage sortie des urnes tombe comme le
laissaient présager les premières
remontées du terrain
ces listes sont bien talonnée par celle
du front national
le marathon médiatique commence à la
préfecture de rouen
toute la soirée il va tenter de faire
bonne figure
donc nous ferons partie probablement des
trois seules régions françaises où ne
seront en tête au soir du premier tour
ma satisfaction c'est que nous avons été
entendus par les normands et qu'en dépit
de l'exaspération absolument
considérable de nos compatriotes nous
sommes arrivés en tête donc donc très
clairement moi je dis aux normands vous
voulez une alternative cette alternative
c'est nous qui pourront vous la fournir
une grossesse après cette entrée
la mine est grave quand vous avez un
pays qui accordent au front national un
score pareil
une voix des français qui sont un état
d'exaspération qui absolument colossal
et donc c'est un message qui est adressé
à toutes les forces démocratiques
et s'il n'était que le front national
aussi acheté républicain l'ambiance
n'est pas à la fête car les chiffres
sont têtus
la gauche peut aussi compter sur des
reports au second tour hervé morin c'est
que la voix sera très étroite